that's Hakeem Jeffries talking about my
next guest joining me now how Judiciary
Committee chair Jim Jordan Congressman
um you laid out for Republicans today
where the Biden impeachment
investigation stands what can you tell
us clearly so the people watching
tonight can understand well there's
there's so many facts that weren't going
to this phase of our constitutional duty
to do oversight and that's why the
speaker did I find it interesting that
this announcement from uh from David
Weiss comes two days after the speaker
announces we're opening an impeachment
inquiry I find that there's been all
kinds of those kind of coincidence that
that have happened along the uh the way
but I think what happened today with
David Weiss this was this was an attempt
to save face because because remember
the context here first there was going
to be no charges against Hunter Biden
then it was the sweetheart deal they
take to the judge that the judge
declines and then they say oh the person
who presided over all that four and a
half years and all that we're going to
make that individual the special counsel
so of course he has to do something and
he does this I think it's largely a
distraction from the bigger potential
issues here which is the Pharaoh issue
and of course the the felony tax
concerns and the statute of limitations
that they let run so you have all that
we're going to look into it we're going
to do our duty we're going to be driven
by the facts and the evidence and the
Constitution and I'm going to say this
again a foreign policy our foreign
policy it raises a question have any
decisions been made that would not have
been made had this connection between
Hunter and top Chinese officials top
Ukrainian officials not have existed
think about the Ukrainian officials
Baris but there are four key factors I
think just sort of capture this all the
first is Hunters put on the board of
Barista second he wasn't qualified to be
on the board of Barista third the people
in Brisbane say hey we need help with DC
to get the pressure this prosecutor is
putting on us fourth Joe Biden goes to
Ukraine and gets the uh the prosecutor
fired and he uses our tax dollars he
leverages our tax money the people the
fourth district of Ohio that I represent
leverages their money to get that done
and when he did it it was an Abrupt turn
from the policy of of the Obama
Administration and frankly what he did
is consistent with the 1023 form and
what the confidential human Source said
took place so if that doesn't warrant
warrants opening an impeachment inquiry
I don't know what does and then you add
to that the layer of how the justice
department has handled this case for
four and a half years I think we have to
investigate that's our job subpoenas did
more go out today and if so to whom and
what more attorneys at doj we've done 13
just related to this with between
chairman attorneys who did well these
were these are attorneys are part of the
investigation Hunter by an investigation
and particularly that meeting that took
place on October 7 2022 that The
Whistleblower Mr shapley said was the
red line meeting where he realized there
is no fixing this I'm going to have to
go forward and talk about how this case
was handled so we want to talk with
people in that meeting and others
associated with it I think it's 13 in
total between chairman Smith chairman
Comer and our committee that we want to
talk to we've talked to three already
the the two already in our committee and
a couple more that have been talked to
by uh by chairman Smith now Mitt Romney
has spoken out on this impeachment
inquiry you know he's announced his
retirement he did his big fever Reno
about how populism is dangerous and we
need to go back to the old ways I guess
when Republicans lost everything
um but this is what he said about the
impeachment issue
house is beginning an impeachment
inquiry
um I haven't heard any allegation of
something that would rise to the level
of a high crime or misdemeanor I think
it'd be very unusual to actually see a
referral of impeachment I I don't expect
that to happen they can inquire uh and
see if there's evidence that that shows
something else I don't think they'll
find that
but he votes to impeach Donald Trump
over January 6 because what evidence was
that that Trump said to compete and also
one of the issues on on the first
ridiculous impeachment which was here's
the here's the ultimate irony they
impeached president Trump saying he
leveraged American tax dollars to get a
policy preference thing done in Ukraine
which he didn't but that's what they
impeached president Trump and now we
have uh Joe Biden engaged in the very
same thing that that is that is to me is
the great the great irony here so
evidence 10 for the big guy no one is
disputed at the big guys Joe Biden 50
for pops you can just go the brand
according to Devon Archer Hunter Biden's
business partner the brand was in fact
Joe Biden multiple bidens receiving
money multiple companies set up multiple
times the White House has changed their
story on this whole situation as a
friend of mine said the other night is
also very prominent lawyer said look if
this stuff is true this is much bigger
than Watergate I mean selling U.S access
influence for more money for your family
member who's the closest family member
to you other than your wife dinners
phone calls and meetings is that is that
not that's that's why we've moved to
this phase of our investigation that's
why I think it was appropriate to do so
and that's why the speaker announced it
two days ago and I think it's it's
interesting that two days later you get
this maybe there's no no Rhyme or Reason
to why it happened two days later but
there's been a number of those kind of
things that have happened close together
Congressman thanks for coming in tonight
great to see you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else